Вчора я вважаю що
це було історичне рішення коли ми
нарешті вже з другої спроби змогли е
більшістю голосів прийняти рішення що
від до відсторонення від керівних
посад представників партії опозиційна
платформа за життя які знаходяться в
Київській міській раді і
[музика]
Таким чином ми вже
продемонстрували іншим регіонам а також
і Верховній Раді про те що треба не
завлікатись цим питанням і активно
позбавлятися проросійських
партій тому що ми не можемо собі
позволити в Україні де йде вже майже
другий рік два роки
повномасштабна
війна наявність партій які
несуть російський наратив в Україні які
можуть бу мають зрадників в своїх рядах
і дуже важливо зараз провести оце
очищення на всіх рівнях влади як на
місцевому так і на
центральному для того щоб ми показали як
українському суспільству всередині так і
всьому світові що у нас немає
толерантності до
е
проросійських політиків і ми будемо ви
викорінювати це
і на
майбутнє щоб вони не мали місця не
тільки
в
районних радах Але і в Верховній Раді
Україні щоб вони не впливали на політику
на прийняття
рішень не мали доступу до таємної
інформації яка може
е
зашкодити веденню військових дій під час
протистояння з нашим російським ворогом
і я хочу сказати що європейська
Солідарність
є локомотиво в цього
процесу вже в
обласній Київській раді було проведення
таке рішення по відстороненню депутатів
від опзж вчора ми це зробили в Київській
раді Я хочу сказати що це не просто було
зробити дуже багато було супротиву і
нерозуміння А чому ми маємо це робити
нібито
і конкретні люди депутати вони і
непогані і ми їх всі знаємо і нам
якось
незручно їх ображати але йдеться тут не
про
персоналії тут ідеться про політичне
рішення і про нашу
нетерпмість взагалі до партії
представники
яких ми знаємо дуже часто
проводили у
російські рішення
е намагалися
е наблизити нас до
Росії дуже багато
колабораціоністів і зрадників які е з
партіє упзж в на Оку зараз вже на
окупованих територіях провели себе
проявили себе е як зрадники саме з
перших Вій е днів війни на нашої
території тому
ее я дякую всім депутатам Київської ради
які вчора віддали свій голос і
підтримали наше рішення
також минулого разу ми проголосували
звернення до Верховної Ради від Київради
щоби вони також очистили свої ряди
від представників партії опозиційна
платформа за життя
і сподіваємося що своїм прикладом ми
покажемо що
треба діяти і треба рухати Вперед і
тільки разом об'єднавши наші зусилля ми
зможемо перемогти нашого ворога